krank sein ist für blockmans wirklich
sehr kontraproduktives passiert nicht
viel ich liege hier im Bett manchmal
wander ich rüber zur Couch schwitzt dann
ein bisschen und leg mich wieder zurück
[Musik]
heute ist Dienstag und gestern am Montag
hätte ich eigentlich schon ein bisschen
was filmen können denn ich habe hier den
ganzen Tag im Bett gelegen mit meinem
Laptop und habe gearbeitet wie aber auch
schon die letzten Tage es war noch nie
so dass ich so viel gearbeitet habe
werde ich krank war und ich will damit
nicht flexen oder sagen so ein toller
mensch ich bin dass ich während ich
krank bin arbeite weil ich finde das
überhaupt nicht gut ich finde das ist
nichts worauf man stolz sein sollte dass
man krank zur Arbeit geht Bullshit aber
es ist einfach so ich habe einfach so
viel gearbeitet die letzten Tage ich
spiele euch jetzt einfach mal nach wie
gestern den Augenarzt angerufen habe ja
hallo hier ist Jessi ich habe einen
Termin für eine Augen OP genau ich bin
krank was machen wir da jetzt das
Mittwoch soll ich warten okay gut ja und
dann sage ich am Mittwoch noch mal
bescheid wie es mir geht wir haben was
ist aber wenn ich zum Beispiel während
der OP husten muss und da so ein Laser
auf mein Auge gerichtet ist
aber soll ich dann Handzeichen dem Arzt
geben alles klar gut ja dann ist das
geklärt danke tschüss das bedeutet ich
weiß noch nicht ob ich die Augen OP
machen kann und der Gedanke macht mich
wirklich fertig weil ich habe mich so
auf die Augen OP gefreut ich kann ich
kann es nicht mehr abwarten ich habe
mich schon darauf eingestellt mich
Weihnachten nicht schminken zu können
weil nach einer Augenlaser Operation
soll man sich zwei Wochen nicht
schminken was er Sinn macht weil das
Auge ist ja wahrscheinlich sehr
empfindlich und man tropft eigentlich
nur antientzündungszeug die ganze Zeit
rein und hofft auf das beste so und dass
das immer noch nicht fest steht ob das
stattfinden kann
ansonsten ist hier die zentrale ich
kümmere mich um Weihnachtsgeschenke
ich habe noch nie in meinem Kopf
abgenommen ausgepackt
steht da immer noch ich hasse das
leute Leute
#leute Timo wo sind deine leute Leute
oder muss ich konzentrieren der fährt
gerade Auto ein Aquarium ist in Berlin
geplatzt und deswegen müssen wir gerade
100 Umwege fahren um dieses geplatzte
Aquarium um zu fahren
zum Fahren dich um zu fahren
jetzt wollen wir das Aquarium aber warum
fahren wenn schon geplatzt ist ähm ja es
ist Freitag mir geht es viel viel besser
ich bin immer noch erkältet das ist
keine Frage die wo muss ich immer noch
um mich kümmern heute muss er sich aus
dem anderen Grund um mich kümmern denn
ich mache die OP Leute ich mach's also
ich habe gedacht dass das ein bisschen
so ein komisches Zeichen ist vom
Universum das ist mich erstmal erkältet
gemacht hat und jetzt ein Aquarium
platzen lässt und wir und Umweg fahren
müssen ich habe schon gesagt wenn wir da
wirklich einen schlimmen Stau reinkommen
und viel später ankommen dann mache ich
das nicht weil dann hat das Universum in
Aquarium platzen lassen damit ich
dieser OP nicht mache aber jetzt Stand
der Dinge
marisi und ich
bin so scheiße aufgeregt ich kann es
eben ohne passen also
ich hoffe ich muss nicht husten wenn sie
da mit dem Laser auf meinem Auge rum
Pointen
ne hast du noch was zu sagen
[Musik]
das weiß ich nicht ja ja
also ich würde auf jeden Fall nicht
machen die Augenoperation aber
an sich ist ja kein gefährlicher
Eingriff
aber ich will auch wir waren aufgeregt
ich bin auch so aufgeregt naja gut okay
ähm ja Berlin sieht ganz schön aus um
diese Uhrzeit
so wir sind jetzt schon wieder zu Hause
und ja also wir konnten drin tatsächlich
nicht filmen weil als Timo sich
hingesetzt hat haben sie zu uns gesagt
ja der junge Mann kann dann in einer
Stunde wieder kommen und dann ist er
halt gegangen hat auch die Kamera
mitgenommen und ich glaube ich hätte vor
Ort auch eigentlich nichts filmen können
ich war definitiv sehr aufgeregt ähm die
ganze Prozedur ich muss sie jetzt einmal
erzählen bevor ich sie vergesse
also man wird in eine Raum gebracht da
kriegt man dann erstmal Augentropfen
ganz viele die
augenbetäuben und dann bekommt man eine
Beruhigungstablette und die kann dich
tatsächlich noch aus meiner
Panikattacken Zeit die heißt Tavor und
die ist die benutzen zum Beispiel
Rettungskräfte wenn Sie an einem
Unfallort sind und dann geben Sie den
Unfall Teilnehmern sie halt auch
teilweise davor damit die halt aus
dieser Panik rauskommen ähm genau und
diese Tage habe ich dann genommen und es
ist eigentlich alles komplett scheißegal
ich dachte man hat eher so also so ein
krasseres Gefühl von man schwebt
irgendwie und macht auch was ihr wollt
aber man ist so viel entspannter und die
Aufregung geht um so vieles runter und
das war schon mal tip top dann wird man
doch eigentlich ganz schnell mit einer
Haube auf dem Gesicht und den Schuhen
irgendwie so eine Haube mit man dann
auch so eine Liege gebracht und dann
rollt man mit dieser liege unter diesen
Laser und dieser Laser ist einfach ein
riesengroß weißer Kasten
und dann sieht man da so ein grünes
Licht und da soll man dann auch drauf
gucken also es wird mit den beiden Augen
einzeln gemacht
dann kommt sie mit einer Klammer von der
Seite und klammert oder sieht man ja
eigentlich alles gar nicht mehr so
richtig ne und klammert einem dann das
Auge auf darf ich dieses betäubt ist ist
es halt nicht so unangenehm und das Auge
wird auch nicht trocken oder so aber es
ist halt schon so ein Gefühl von sind
aufgeklappt das Auge und ja dann ist man
da auf dieser
grüne Licht und dann muss man ganz still
halten und zu diesem grünen Licht gucken
und dann mittig gucken weil das kann
natürlich bewegt sich auch so ein
bisschen also muss man mittig bleiben
die ganze Zeit so Panik dass ich es
nicht schaffe mit ich zu gucken weil ich
habe einmal irgendwie den grünlich
gefunden hat sie gesagt nein weiter
geradeaus und dann hatte ich schon
scheiße ich mache hier was falsch und
dann ist es so schwer zu beschreiben
dann geht es quasi los und ich dachte
irgendwie da wird auf mein Auge was
drauf gelegt weil es da little Lisa aus
als ob die Sicht von außen nach innen
einfach so von so immer milchiger zu
immer und durchsichtig
ich weiß wird und dieser dieser grüne
Licht wird immer schwächer im
Hintergrund und so sieht richtig aus als
ob irgendwas zu wachsen würde und dann
wird man rausgeschoben und das ist jetzt
wirklich eine hier triggerwarnung wenn
ihr sowas nicht gerne hört aber dann
hört ihr euch wahrscheinlich schon die
ganze Story hier gerade nicht an
ja und dann klappt sie so das den die
Haut hoch und dann liegt irgendwas auf
meinem Auge was sie wegnehmen muss und
dann hat die da es hat sich angefühlt
als ob sie mit einer pinzettel die nicht
da weh getan hat aber man hat es ein
bisschen gefühlt ähm wenn er viel Zettel
da im Auge so rum so sucht und dann hat
sie da irgendwas dann spielt sie noch
mal nach tupft da irgendwann nach klappt
das irgendwie zu und dann habe ich noch
mal eine Kontaktlinse oben drauf
bekommen und das ist auch auf beiden
Seiten ja und das hat alles jetzt
insgesamt so 20 Minuten gedauert mit
Betäubung bekommen mit bla bla
und morgen habe ich dann meinen ersten
Untersuchungstermin ja das ist jetzt so
stand der dinge ich trage jetzt diese
Brille weil wir draußen waren jetzt gehe
ich mich gleich noch mal schlafen legen
ich darf meine Augen nämlich drei
Stunden nicht öffnen ich werde sie aber
glaube ich gleich doch noch einmal
Tropfen weil die Ärzte also die Helferin
der das nicht so ganz genau beschrieben
was jetzt machen soll die meinte so ja
kannst jetzt schon anfangen zu tropfen
weil sie meinte ja Augen halt nicht
aufmachen aber man soll halt irgendwie
auch gleichzeitig Tropfen
naja und dann lasse ich die Augen
erstmal vier Stunden geschlossen oder
dreieinhalb oder was auch immer tja
das ist es gerade ne ich bin richtig
happy dass sie es gemacht habe meine
erste Eindruck war jetzt positiv der
Eingriff ist halt da kann man nichts
dagegen sagen das ist einfach es fühlt
sich alles super weird an man hat keine
großen Schmerzen aber da habe ich dass
man so hilflos da irgendwie liegt und
nicht ganz genau weiß was man einfach
passiert das ist ein bisschen wird
ja aber ansonsten bin ich sehr happy da
sind hinter mir
lecker
richtig gut geschlafen ich will auch
gleich weiterschlafen
[Musik]
und
ja
scharf aber ist nur ein bisschen
verklebt
die muss heute Abend vielleicht sagen
wir haben ein Antibiotikum noch
irgendeine Medizin und tropfen
und das muss
viermal am Tag
ja viermal am Tag jeweils ein Tropfen
pro Auge
das andere
super
auf zum Kontrolltermin aber nicht
vergessen
mir einen Bläschen
empfindlich
oder
komplett Gefahren
[Musik]
meine Sicht ist bei 100% ihr könnt mich
jetzt ab sofort Vanessa das Adleraugen
nennen ich kann euch auch alles Vorlesen
Shishi Pop Mauern was steht da kommen
sie der Grippe zuvor ja sitzen ins Auge
reingeguckt das sieht alles super aus
außer der Bluterguss das ist halt
ja was sollen wir noch sagen ne
Operation geglückt
aber das einzige was ich noch sehe ist
halt immer so ein Schimmer um Sachen
aber die Ärztin hat gerade gesagt das
ist noch vollkommen in Ordnung das
dauert halt ein paar Tage bis man halt
wirklich 100 % sieht und bis dann alle
Nebenwirkungen sag ich mal weg sind
und jetzt gibt's Rahmen zu Belohnung wir
hatten noch im gerade überlegt in der
Mall of Berlin noch ein bisschen
Weihnachtsshopping zu machen aber es ist
Samstag es ist Samstag 14 Uhr ey das das
wäre absolute Hölle gewesen da dann
durch die Läden zu gehen
ja
vor allem mit Hunger und Foodcard in
einem Einkaufszentrum ist okay kann man
machen aber es ist halt nie so geil ne
tschüss